brazilian artist Alex Fleming has been
living in Berlin for 22 years now his
favorite spot in the German capital is
the mower part in the Berlin pencil bag
district ich liebe here in moorpark
design vine I love it here in the
mauerpark because it's so full of
history the border between East and West
Berlin ran right through here I admire
Germany for not handing this bit of the
former death strip over to the
developers and letting them build it up
son pot it's been preserved as a park
that wouldn't be possible in Brazil in
Brazil ensign Fleming studio is just a
5-minute walk from the park here he
creates his paintings collages and
installations his works have been
exhibited at galleries around the world
from Washington DC to Geneva Sydney and
Barcelona rio de janeiro soprano and
berlin
Brazilian his teeth in my nazila get
baked Brazil is etched deep in my soul
miaka I've realized that everything I
paint has to do with my childhood in
Brazil their father with that country's
spaciousness and the many colors you
only find in the tropics dining them
talking via everything here is grey and
brown in Brazil everything's pink and
turquoise two-piece much of his art has
a political side such as the flying
carpet series it alludes to the 911
attacks in New York with oriental rugs
shaped like airplanes or the
bodybuilders series for which maps of
war zones are superimposed on muscular
torsos he dedicated his installation
Galileo Galilei to its namesake it'll be
opening in Sao Paulo together with the
soccer world cup but Alex Fleming takes
a critical view of the sporting
extravaganza is the tightest of M de
Velde this is the most expensive world
cup in history that's just crazy God's
dougie we have to be against it it's
been poorly the most times I support the
people in Brazil who are taking to the
streets again feeders are there are many
things that need changing their first
the quality of Justice has to improve a
lot a gite most field design second Isis
police brutality Mustangs I third and
corruption must and treated equal Sean
moose endin
even as a child Alex Fleming had close
ties to Germany he had a German
grandmother who taught him to speak the
language he came to the still divided
Berlin for the first time in 1986 he
returned in 1991 after reunification and
stayed on here in Berlin hobby hibiki
food here in Berlin I get a feeling I
never have in Brazil and the other way
around 20 does he come army in Berlin
I'm glad that I can walk the streets at
night did not be mugged you can't do
that in brazil brazilian Lyda
deflectors up what I don't like is that
people are almost constantly in a bad
mood Oh standee hobby but then I'm
Brazilian so I'm cool with it look I
don't care in Berlin he stays in close
touch with other Brazilians they'd get
together regularly at the part of
Berlin's oldest beer garden
you have a feel but I have lots of
Brazilian friends I love my german
friends too but my Brazilian friends are
closer we come together in the beer
garden and swamp football stickers and
drink beer showing his colors it doesn't
take long to figure out who Alyx Fleming
would like to see when the world cup
files in enfield in case it comes down
to the finals of our dreams germany vs
brazil of course my heart goes to Brazil
Brazil Brazil and Brazil no question
here even though Alex Fleming has been a
German citizen for about 10 years now
he's still a true Brazilian at heart